[Music]  I've heard tales of your kind Witcher  you're a mutant created by magic  roaming the continents we don't want  your kind here hunting monsters rock  race I thought you'd have found or horns  or something  I had them filed down  people call you I wanted to  [Music]  [Applause]  why not kill them because that I am what  they say I have all of our choices draw  our destinies closer  he's out there there's still hope  fine carrots for me  don't judge me they say witches can't  feel human emotion what do you believe  in evil  lesser  [Music]  greater  it's all assayer  consistory Lee  the old destiny  my concrete active  if you dismissal  unleash  full community upon us all  I'll take that chance  [Music]  [Music]